trouve qu'il ya une dette qui s'approche
c'est celle du 30 novembre et puis c'est
la date à laquelle les députés vont
devoir se rattacher financièrement un
parti actuellement tirer solar vous
devait être rattachée j'imagine aux
républicains à quel parti allez-vous
vous rattachez d'ailleurs cette dame
rose est une vraie question
parce que se faire virer par un parti
politique à qui vous avez donné l'argent
de votre élection
bah pardon mais à ce moment là qu'ils
rendent l'argent qu'ils touchent les
républicains a lié à l'élection vrai que
là moi même et de franck riester parce
que s'est posée de cette enveloppe à la
moi j'ai jamais eu besoin des partis
politiques pour le faire élire
j'ai été élu face à claude guéant en
2012 sans aucune investiture à boulogne
billancourt et croyez moi je ne vais pas
ça fait bien longtemps que je mets pas
les logos dans tous les sens pour
essayer de dire et et voter pour ce
parti un parti moi je suis candidat -
deuxièmement la réorganisation de la vie
politique
elle s'opère en ce moment moi je pense
profondément qu'il ya un espace 1 entre
la république dans marche qui existent
et les républicains donc un parti